oh my gosh i was just about to end the
stream
all this timing thanks to karu reading
with four
four four four that's um
that's not really a meme number i can't
i just finished a viewer tournament
i was trying to promote what's coming up
in the eventual streams
okay i'll stick around i guess what do i
do
i could rap i have to get coaching from
levy how to rap
we'll make an arena tournament how about
uh
and we'll dedicate it to gm hikaru three
two okay oh chess people's playing zero
oh i'm playing chastry what is this
okay uh nope is working
chastry playing like hikaru i wanted to
la following hikaru with the other day
but then i was black
and recaro didn't feed and karo his
thing
i just blunder upon i kind of did
but it's okay
uh i guess we'll keep trading can i
prevent
preventing castling
ah but not preventing queen side
castling i am threatening a pawn
so king's kind of tied down to defending
the pawn
i'm in good shape never mind i was
thinking about playing like a4
i probably should still play a4
preventing black from playing a4
so i want to keep the king in the center
and then eventually check me at the king
ultimate goal of chess preventing g5 is
ooh
uh
this might backfire terribly but free
food
regretting eating the free food it's
actually a almost brilliant
is this working i could
take what is this witchcraft
taking doesn't quite work
95 doesn't really work
wait a minute i'm kind of in trouble i
have uh
h5 doesn't work either what is this
queen f maybe just
f
people have to pay respects takes takes
this g file's so strong what is this
i might just be losing here
unfortunately i want to try and fight
though
h4 takes takes h6
i thought my opening was so strong
so if i take oh i can take and play
bishop g5 back
this is probably the way to go i took a
while to find
so i'm not dead but i'm i'm under
serious pressure because this is a
scary move
i feel like the life lesson is don't
accept free food
from people that want to destroy you
so i'm down about a minute
b99 is overrated already has two wins
and a little international master
pumpkin is playing
um h4 is legal
takes probably takes
it's really uncomfortable though
how bad can it be
so the goal
what is my goal
the goal is to do this and this as
quickly
as wait what oh he wants to meet me on
h2
ah
i'm up a pawn i'm up a pawn somehow
i'm down a ton of time
okay i want to play queen e5
okay so successfully defending h2
a5 is tender but i can't really take
it yet okay forking the ponds
you have to eat your food with a fork
uh play h3 oh it's so tricky i think i
can take it though
my rook might regret its life decision
yeah it's regretting its decisions
so i'm gonna be down the exchange
and super passive
uh have to trade rooks i guess
b3 ba
pre-move time
oh no f5 is kind of hurtful
oh no my bishop's getting trapped
or not still alive
i have four seconds i should probably
resign
don't hurt me
i'm getting hurt
okay i resign or flag okay
uh good game chess weave wow that was a
cool game
i spent so long on that the middle game
moment
i actually got the position i guess uh
the mistakes i made was taking free food
like the pawns i took actually caused
serious damage
especially on a5 i was very
devious by the weeb to trap my rook
okay let's recover do i tilt dessert
oh no my peak rating not stafford gambit
because why not
i'm gonna try and win this tournament
but to win the tournament i have to go
insane i guess
this is a fun line
this is also a drawing line except i
want to play for a win
knight g3 knight g3 is not objectively a
good move i should have gone for a draw
uh oh i can take here
opponent wait am i winning in the final
position
i am oh because queen g
three some idea okay that was nice
let's go that was a nice quick win
i was slightly confused there not
expecting the game to end like
immediately like that
easy clap haven't clapped in a while
wait i want to clap my mic
did that work like people heard that
right like the sound
the sound thing should be working okay
i'll get to work again and
try and keep easy clapping
okay
so i want to play hyper hyper
aggressively
oh uh it's taken with a pawn
the thing about this line it might be
hard to win quickly
unless my opponent plays this
style of hikaru
then queen is doing some damage let's
play this first open the bishop
development is more important than
material
yeah so now the bishop has access to the
square
i think i want to play this first
so if i played this uh rook can go back
to g8
now if the rook goes back to g8 i take
on f6
okay with a night trade
thank you mons bam laza mazni
a subbing for four months
okay let's play this move we might end
up trading a lot
or i might end up winning the queen
i'm probably not objectively never mind
uh after rook h7 i'm
not sure how much better i was
right here we'll develop
i want to play this move maybe depending
where the queen goes
and light wants to come in
opponent is trying to resist
yes so the the bishop attacked my rook
but i counter attack the king
has to return to its sad place
now if it moves here i'm set up for
discovery
check
okay probably should have taken
should have taken with rook actually
but the pawn is undefendable
so 18 minutes left in the tournament
leaders have 10 points
um still not mating by force it's close
though
oh maybe i can get a smother mate
i'm going to try and set up a smothered
mate because why not
it's dubious i'll play rook b7
oh no my rook oh no
oh no black's time oh that can take it
okay
okay let's go i wanted to sack the rook
and then smother me
but it wasn't guaranteed um
so got a couple berserk wins
i have to clap again yeah the clapping
doesn't really work
because i have the noise suppression
so do people even hear that
kind of i think but it's not like overly
loud i don't
think okay staffer gave a time
i'm using a filter it's like a
an ai filter that suppresses any noise
that isn't speech
so any like random background noise
um it shouldn't pick up
bishop d3 is still probably playable
now the question is how insane do i want
to go
i kind of want to go insane
i don't think that knight takes f2 is
good but it looks fun
actually looks really fun king here etc
i get some temporary initiative i guess
queen e4
we could trade queens
yeah i was fighting uh or i wanted to
mate there
wait am i mating in two almost missed
queen f4
as maiden two white's only legal move
is this
pretty sure that it's not supposed to be
good for some reason
hey it's thirsty monster if you're just
joining i won
in 10 moves with the stafford uh
yeah so what is white supposed to do
king f1 this is all fine oh queen e3
is only move not to lose okay
we keep going so i'm top six
shout out to thirsty monster appreciate
the raid
i'm getting a good number of raids today
i was supposed to end the stream
uh like 20 minutes ago but then hecarim
raided
so the stream keeps going let's work
again
the gambits keep going as well
this might not be a gambit
um yeah we'll play some kind of
[Music]
line against the vienna
i'm still going to try and be aggressive
here like maybe go for some quick
h6 g5
oh
okay yeah i think it's time to take
the structure is slightly annoying
because my uh my bishop's a bit stuck
at the same time this diagonal is very
strong for black
white wants to play this move play this
move if knight a4 i check and that has
to go back
and now with the pawn on a4 uh the
knight can no longer come here
because rook supports the pawn
yeah that's a move i have this move
if this i might play might go for the
dark square invasion
also this bishop is tied down to the
pawn
so it's kind of pleasant for for black
this move
or no let's play bishop d7
do some development
[Music]
uh
have to move quicker
g5 or d maybe d5
no play this move so i can no longer
castle queen side
and put the queen on e7 over defending
the pawn because i want to castle queen
sign
in the event that the king side opens
i really keep the pace here rating is on
the line
okay i don't mind the trading even
though i lose my bishop
i would uh okay here i can take and win
the pawn
if we were to trade i get the e-file
here i get the e-pawn
still sharp position and
time is dwindling i'm trying to
undermine these pawns
white still can't castle queen is clutch
i had queen e3 queen e3 was an option
there'd be
i should have gone for that it's still a
threat queenie two week trading
i fork
yeah white's under a lot of pressure
here hey it's another raid from
kukulbooch
welcome back i really hope i'm not
butchering your name
also my time what is my time ah that
doesn't work anymore
d5 no uh move back and
push if you're just joining i have 15
seconds to win this game
so i have to stay focused keep pushing
or pushing
more fun to pronounce use as actual use
or pronounce use as ooze
okay i could have taken the knight
let's take the knight and then take the
pawn maybe
it's almost meat
oh it's a fork let's go
okay plenty of time
queen somewhere
or rook somewhere there we go okay
just enough time there
shout out to kugelbooch guten
guten abend guten aben to germany
you're the third reader in like 20
minutes we had hikaru
thirsty monster and kugelbooch some
legends of twitch
okay so i'm trying for those just
joining i'm running a viewer tournament
you can join the tournament i'm trying
to win it there's 10 minutes left
i'm berserking the rest of the games
currently
in fourth place we have a scandi
i'll play this line
defend the pawn and then take the thing
okay this is already pretty pleasant
i mean black is playing some kind of
gambit style
has f file has some f2 pressure
i mean my goal is probably just a castle
play knight e4 and
either simplify or attack
keep my bishop i don't mind g5
so f2 is covered
yeah this is actually pretty solid
i think you dreams of melody subbing for
11 months
uh let's play this
ooh let's just simplify everything
whenever you're up a pawn you can
usually assume that the kingpin ending
will be winning for you
because i have the three on two so it
should be enough to win
i play c4 to get the e4 square for the
king
eventually i might have to be patient
though
and play some waiting moves
ooh did i mess up
play this and then gf g5 g4 i guess
it should still be winning i hope
yeah i think it's still winning there's
a line takes takes d4
i have to play king g3 king f5 king f3
and then it's perpetual zukwang okay
this is also winning
f5 incoming
could pre-move this
yeah so the my king is within range of
catching the h
pawn well within the box
try and meet efficiently okay let's go
no time to waste
catching up to the pumpkin or at least
hoping to
21 points flagville has 28.
yeah that first loss to check what
happened to chess weave
where's chesweeb oh my watch is
reminding me to breathe
no time to breathe did chest weight just
beat me and then withdraw
oh i'm playing slovham okay
okay deep breath
oh berserking okay almost forgot thanks
for reminding me
i was too focused on breathing uh
oh somehow knows a stafford kind of
um i think d5 is okay
now we're actually getting a nice line
or a knights line
um at this point i'm kind of just
improvising
play this move my knight is awkward
this is actually not a great position
for me
this is night
i feel like life is just one
long improvisation
okay bishops are
in a single file line
can i take that so many things i want to
take
can take this
i think everything's covered king is
safe
i might be threatening this move
i gotta do it it's too tempting it might
be dubious but it might be winning
uh check their check
let's move
oh wait a minute if takes i could
consider that
yeah that's a really good move i can
take
what was i thinking oh that didn't work
at all
i'm just down the bishop da and there's
a may threat
of this move
i'm in some trouble here
[Music]
let's take this way okay bullet time
ah that doesn't work at least i have
pawns
please take my pawn there okay let's
take white's pawns
pawns are well placed actually
let's go okay that was a close game good
games of ham
i have 26 points might be hard to catch
up to first
but can i muster to first
oh the pumpkin has paused a pausing
pumpkin
more peaceful than smashing pumpkin okay
b99 is i think the mainline night or
but let's play staff right now it's like
the eco code
uh okay we'll have um some kind of four
nights
so with h3 my plan is to play g5 g4
avoid the symmetry
so i want to finish this game and get
one more game in
which might be difficult but might be
possible
knight h2 coming i want to save the
bishop
bishop f5 if not in nh2
oh that's a move too
[Music]
not what i wanted okay let's play this
move have to accept the fact we're
trading
okay queen d7
so i'm trying to make the game sharp oh
i blundered though
yeah i can't take really either way
i kind of have to take though
i'm in big trouble here don't hurt me
i'm down the bishop but i'm up on time
uh let's play this move and then attack
wow
a ruthless move
okay can still be aggressive
the problem is the bishop always defends
g2
so i just have to have a lot of
attackers
or deflect the bishop or win on time
or win the bishop and then win on time
um let's take
ah that was a wrong move
okay going into this line so my root
cover is a7 which is useful
this move
oh no don't mimi or hurt me
here we go
let's go or flag me
let's go ah
the tournament's almost over at least i
won
but the tournament's over good job to
flagville
maybe flagging the way to victory
okay that was a fun fun game fun
tournament
managed to recover after losing to the
weeb
i break even i think i broke even in
terms of raiding
oh good job to subham too get some more
confetti
yeah it's the most uh unemotional
confetti ever
since the spelling bee champion